[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
50000 personnes à temps frisquet mais du
soleil à gogo pour la plus grande
épreuve européenne de l'année aux
droites le Prix d'Amérique à Vincennes
comme les gens heureux les grandes
courses hippiques sont presque toujours
sans histoire aux eaux la jument numéro
1 du turf français n'a pas déçu les
parieurs dès le départ menait un beau
battant elle a pris la tête pour tout le
monde la course était déjà terminée ozo
est une jument étonnante et la mauvais
caractère en cours celle ne décolèrent
pas il paraît qu'elle n'aime pas son
driver entre les lui c'est le mariage
forcé elle obéit donc mais elle se fâche
et elle le montre en giflant son driver
d'une queue vengeresse
[Musique]
tout cela n'empêche pas ce couple
insolite de remporter de nombreuses
victoires avec autant d'aisance que ce
Prix d'Amérique
Zoé sandriver ne s'arrêteront pas en si
bon chemin avant que tout cela ne
finisse par un divorce
cette année au rallye de Monte-Carlo
c'est avec la panoplie du parfait homme
des neiges à bord de sa voiture que
chacun des concurrents a pris le départ
rien n'a été épargné au pilote tempête
de neige vers GLA route bloquée par des
congères de 2 mètres de haut ainsi tous
les concurrents venant d'Athènes sont
restés en route quelque part en
Yougoslavie ils ont dû prendre l'avion
pour arriver à Monaco c'est un comble
sur les 296 voitures au départ des 7
itinéraires 102 seulement pu rejoindre
la Principauté tant bien que mal puisque
27 seulement d'entre elles sont arrivés
dans les délais
après tant d'épreuve le soleil de Monaco
a fait risette à ceux qui ont eu la
chance de terminer c'est un récidiviste
le géant suédois Carlson sur une voiture
suédoise également une petite sable 5
chevaux qui a remporté le 32e rallye de
Monte-Carlo il avait en effet déjà gagné
l'an dernier
[Musique]
le prince Rainier la princesse Grèce ont
vivement féliciter les rescapés de ce
rallye qui espèrent encore faire mieux
la prochaine fois
[Musique]
n'est-ce pas monsieur Carlson jamais
deux sans trois
[Musique]
ce dossier de mastodonte c'est le
dernier cri des engins de transport des
forces du Pacte atlantique malgré son
poids et son volume il se promène
allègrement à tout terrain avec
l'agilité d'une chenille il est vrai que
chacune de ces roues est complètement
indépendante des autres c'est le
monsieur passe partout les armées
alliées il n'hésite même pas à se
mouiller quand c'est nécessaire
il ne lui manque plus que des ailes pour
voler
mais patience le camion roulant
naviguant et volant c'est sans doute
pour demain
à Dublin le match France - Irlande de
rugby a bien mal commencé pour les
Français qui encaissent un essai
transformé signé Aurélie après 20
minutes de jeu 5-0 on se rappelle à ce
moment la défaite de la France devant
l'école
et puis sur mets les ouvertes la balle
fuse vers les trois quarts français Guy
Boniface profite de l'aubaine
la situation est complètement renversée
quelques minutes plus tard sur un drop
de Pierre alberté donc à la mi-temps six
à 5 pour la France c'est un peu trop
flatteur il faut l'avouer
[Musique]
les Français prennent la chance du bout
des doigts passe croisé d'Al balade des
jours à André Boniface drop trois points
de plus
[Musique]
à peine remis de leur surprise les
Irlandais vont encaisser un nouvel essai
de débordement que marque imparablement
darrouilles entre les poteaux tout cela
est bien conçu mais l'équipe d'Irlande
n'est pas dans un bon jour les Français
ont réellement une réussite incroyable
dans les 22 mètres irlandais encore une
fois la balle repart tous les trois
quarts Français sont en attaque daroui
marque son troisième essai de la journée
24 à 5 pour la France mais c'est trop
beau pour être vrai attendons la
confirmation devant les Anglais
à Paris dans le salon Murat de l'Élysée
au cours d'une séance solennelle le
général de Gaulle et le chancelier à
denauer en présence des principaux
ministres français et allemands ont
signé le texte du traité qui associe
désormais France et Allemagne sur le
plan de la politique étrangère de la
défense de l'Information et de la
Culture le président français et le
chancelier allemand se sont déclarés
convaincus que cet événement historique
est une étape essentielle sur la voie de
l'Europe unie car illustre d'une manière
éclatante l'esprit de coopération entre
les deux pays
depuis bientôt un mois et demi le monde
entier à froid recroquevillé sous la
neige la ville de Varsovie s'est
transformée en désert polaire ou
s'aventure parfois quelques patients
dans le port les bateaux eux aussi
s'endorment dans leur cocon de glace
par tout ailleurs en Europe fleuve et
canaux se sont changés en long ruban
givrée sur lesquels sont immobilisés
bateau et remorqueurs cette paralysie
des voies de communication et
catastrophique le charbon reste sur les
quais alors qu'il se fait de plus en
plus rare dans les habitations
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en Californie on n'avait pas vu cela
depuis 50 ans moins 17 dans la vallée de
sanihakim réputé pour son éternel
printemps pour sauver les oranges
frigorifiées par le gel des brasero ont
été allumés bien inutilement d'ailleurs
la plupart des arbres étaient déjà morts
et cet hiver n'en finit pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un coup de baguette magique celle d'un
grand financier et megève est devenu
subitement la station de ski la plus
luxueuse du monde une station que
contemple accrochait dans la neige un
portrait géant de Jacqueline Kennedy
tracé par son admirateur numéro 1 le
peintre René casassus
[Musique]
le clou de se Megève New Look pour
milliardaire en vacances c'est l'hôtel
du Mont d'Arbois
[Musique]
il cultive le superflu beaucoup plus
encore que le nécessaire et on aime
également l'insolite dans le nouveau
paradis du ski après
[Musique]
et quel panorama
jolie passe-temps pour un skieur blasé
après le calme de la piscine dans la
neige à la mairie de Megève celouragan
on se croirait au métro Concorde à 6h du
soir et tout cela pour l'événement
historique de l'année Sacha Distel
abandonne ses copains il épouse Francine
Bréau en toute intimité 150 photographes
et des admirateurs comme s'il en
pleuvait
[Musique]
depuis qu'elle a battu à plate couture
toutes les vedettes féminines du ski
international à Saint-Gervais Annie
famos le nouveau bébé champion français
et désormais elle aussi la proie des
photographes
[Musique]
honore de l'équipe de France est moins
heureux avec ses garçons qui n'ont pas
tellement brillé dans la coupe Émile
allait dans la descente en tout cas
Viola et peria sont bien songeur avant
l'épreuve
peria le voici en pleine course dans le
mur de bornée c'est là que va se jouer
la victoire de l'Autrichien Zimmermann
vous allez voir comme
maintenant toujours au même endroit
c'est mieux que peyria qui lit va
terminer ce goût Zimmermann le voilà
[Musique]
clé comme une flèche dès le départ
ici ils font sa 120 à l'heure sur une
neige dure comme du bois chaque bosse
chaque secousses est un supplice pour
les gens
[Musique]
il arrive au mur de bornée c'est là
qu'il va gagner ces quatre secondes
d'avance sur Jean-Claude Killy et ses 10
secondes sur Périgueux
un bon de 15 m
[Musique]
Zimmerman et cette année le meilleur
descendeur du monde
[Musique]
il fonce jusqu'à la dernière seconde
résultat 80 de moyenne horaire record de
peria archi battu peria qui en pleurait
de dépistes et consoles et de ses
déboires en descente en remportant le
slalom il reçoit les félicitations de
ses amis Roger Vadim et Sacha Distel et
Madame Sacha Distel y joint un baiser
sur l'ajout de son ancien camarade de
l'équipe de France
[Musique]